this was the first sign of autism that I
noticed in my son at six and a half
months he has since been diagnosed with
high-functioning autism and OCD
he usually Falls at least once so try to
keep pillows around the table so he can
not crash and burn and they're right but
he's probably gonna stand here for like
an hour just playing with this thing if
you know anything about autism he does
it a lot with all kinds of toys like
this I'll do this you see he does it
with everything whether he's got empty
fists or not
where's your toy your toy fell on the
ground
get your toy be careful
hey Bugaboo
Hey
you have a toy
are you gonna stand up like a big boy
yeah big boomy oh my goodness big boy hi
hey hey hey hey big boy Raphael Raphael
careful you're Chokin yourself honey
send up good boy
then baba Baba
if you'd like to see more we make videos
every single day of our everyday life
here in Israel so please subscribe to
our daily vlogging Channel full a living
we making videos every day thank you for
watching have a great day
[Music]